there are arguments in which one person
will get so upset
that they start to behave in ways that
range far beyond the imagined norms
of civilized conduct they speak in a
highly pitched voice
they exaggerate they weep they beg their
words become
almost incoherent they pull their own
hair they bite their own hand
they roll on the floor unsurprisingly it
can become supremely tempting for their
partner
to assert that this dramatic behavior
means that they've evidently
gone mad and to close them down on this
score
to press the point home the unagitated
partner
may start to speak in a preternaturally
calm way
as if addressing an unruly dog or a
red-faced two-year-old
they may assert that since the partner
has grown so unreasonable
there doesn't seem to be any point in
continuing the conversation
a conclusion which drives the distressed
partner to further paroxysms and
convulsions
it's natural to propose that the person
who loses their temper
in the course of an argument thereby
loses any claim
to credibility whatever point they may
be trying to make
seems automatically to be invalidated by
the fact that they're doing so
while in a chaotic state the only
priority
seems to be to shift attention to how
utterly awful and immature
they're being it's evident the one who
is calm
is good the one who is frothing and
spluttering is a [ __ ]
unfortunately both partners end up
trapped in an unproductive cycle that
benefits neither of them
there's a moment when the calm one may
turn and say since you're mad there's no
point in talking to you
the awareness in the raging lover's mind
that as they rant and flail
they are throwing away all possibility
of being properly attended to or
understood
feeds their ever-mounting sense of panic
they become
yet more demented and exaggerated
further undermining their credibility in
the discussion
hearing their condition diagnosed as
insane by the calm one
serves to reinforce a suspicion that
perhaps they really are mad
which in turn weakens their capacity not
to be so
they lose confidence that there might be
any reasonable aspect to their distress
which could theoretically be explained
in a clear way
if only they could stop crying i'm not
going to listen to you
any further if you keep making such a
fuss the calm partner might go on to say
prompting ever more of precisely this
fuss
the frustrated one is gradually turned
into a case study
fit only for clinical psychology or a
straight jacket
they are as we might put it pathologized
held up as someone who's actually crazy
rather than as an ordinary human who's
essentially quite sane
but has temporarily lost their
self-possession
on account of an extremely difficult
situation
on the other side of the equation the
person who remains calm
is automatically cast by their own
serene nature and subtle skills at
public relations
as decent and reasonable but we should
bear in mind
that it is at least in theory entirely
possible to be cruel
dismissive stubborn harsh and wrong and
keep one's voice utterly steady just as
one can
equally well be red-nosed whimpering and
incoherent
and have a point we need to keep in mind
a heroically generous attitude
rage and histrionics can be the symptoms
of a desperation that sets in
when a hugely important intimate truth
is being blatantly ignored or denied
without the uncontrolled person being
either evil
or monstrous obviously the method of
delivery is drastically unhelpful
obviously it would always be better if
we didn't start to cry
but it's not beyond understanding or in
theory at least
forgiveness if we were to do so it's
horrible and frightening
to witness someone getting intensely
worked up but with the benefit of
perspective
their inner condition calls for deep
compassion
rather than a lecture we should remember
that only someone who internally felt
their life was in danger
would end up in a mess in a discussion
we should keep this in mind
because sometimes it will be us who fall
into a deranged state
we won't always be the aggrieved
cooler-headed party
we should all have a little film of
ourselves at our very worst moments
from which we replay brief highlights as
we witness the other frothing and
shouting and so remember that while we
ourselves
looked mad our contortions were only the
outer signs of an inner agony
at being unable to make ourselves
understood on a crucial point
by the person we relied on we can stay
calm with almost everyone in our lives
if we lose our temper with our partners
it is at best in part because we're so
invested in them
and our joint futures we shouldn't
invariably hold it against someone
that they behave in a stricken way it
isn't probably
a sign that they are mad or horrible
rather as we should have the grace to
remember
it's just that they love and depend on
us
very much our emotional barometer
is a tool that can help us to more
clearly explain our moods
click the link on screen now to find out
more